sponses the coca-cola world fund lecture
we are delighted to host Debra bottom
the Bernard L sports professor of
political economy at Johns Hopkins
University School of Advanced
International Studies as well as its
director of the International
Development Development Program and the
director of the China Africa research
initiative as the speaker for today's
coca-cola well-funded lecture at Yale
the lecture was established in 1992 by
the late Robert lazette a former chair
and CEO of the coca-cola company and
value as the Yale class of 1953
professor provenance teaching and
research focuses on international
development strategies on governance and
foreign a she's twice won Fulbright
research Awards and is the recipient of
fellowships from the Council on Foreign
Relations the Woodrow Wilson
international center for scholars and
research branch from the UK Economic and
Social Research Council than the UK
Center for Economic Policy and research
she served as a consultant for many
institutions including trip conspiracy
international the UN the World Bank the
African Development Bank USAID and she's
often provided commentary to the
Financial Times The New York Times The
Guardian CNN NPR al-jazeera and MSNBC
she's been a visiting scholar at the
World Bank a senior research fellow at
the International Food Policy Policy
Research Institute and she's advised
more than a dozen governments on China
Africa relations she is a winner of a
very well-known book called the dragon's
gift the real story of China
in Africa and indeed it was through
meeting that book that I first became
aware of professor bergen's worked most
of us have this kind of cartoon strip
image of Chinese activity in Africa as
give to extract any natural resources
and little or anything else but that's
just one snapshot of one phase of
China's very long development in Africa
which she shows in incredibly rich
detail in that book was first of all
shaped by their experience of China of
Japanese Imperialism and then we had
responded and evolved and changed in in
reaction to various things including
development fads in the West as every
decade there's a new fad in the World
Bank and the IMF and the Washington
Consensus changes and often when it
changes Chinese in investment strategy
has has responded to those and moved
into things that have been vacated which
shows how they have Chinese policymakers
on their international aid and
investment have a learning curve they
learn from their mistakes they adapt and
they evolve
she also shows in very rich detail that
they're not only interested in
extractive industries if you look at
what they're doing in Mauritius for
example all kinds of other things and
then in the last parts of that book
she talks about their evolution into
partnerships with local governments with
local firms and with international firms
from Europe
and house we're doing working and doing
investment in Africa so it's really this
book it's the gold standard for research
on what China has done in Africa we were
just discussing all the other credible
credible amount of and evidence that she
was able to get hold up about Chinese
thinking on development that most of us
would have guessed would be available
and the book was published I think 2009
was it yeah so we kept waiting for
something to come along that would
update all of this but there really are
we reading pretty much what's been
coming out and there hasn't been
anything that's come along remotely as
good that has blown up to date the
Chinese thinking until now and so
Deborah browning and patch the new book
will Africa feed China that is the
source of her remarks today and we get a
sneak preview of believe the publication
day that the book is actually today so
congratulations and welcome does this
work
No yes yeah okay all right okay um thank
you that was a lovely introduction you
guys really do it well here so thank you
all for coming
I know there was a lot of competition
the main competition was the sunshine
and I really appreciate that you spent
the last part of this beautiful day that
you're going to be spending that coming
to to hear me talk about my new book so
thank you very much for that and the
book did just officially get published
today although I have this copy so I was
able to get a hold of it a little bit
really okay so if I can work this
what does China wat I was just talking
to two students about this what does
China want and I think this is one of
the questions that we've been asking
ourselves a lot in the United States in
recent years what does China want and
how will China seek to meet its needs
and what does this mean for the United
States what does it mean for the rest of
the world China's rise is probably the
most important geopolitical phenomenon
of certainly of this century young as it
yieldeth and in my research I'm very
mindful of something that John pomfret
from the Washington Post said a few
years ago and that is overestimating the
challenge from China could be just as
dangerous as under estimating it so I
keep that in mind when I'm doing my
research now China is often portrayed as
a threat in Africa so this is the idea
of overestimating the challenge we can
see for example this Economist picture
of the new colonialist
up there the idea that China's reaching
in with a big communist hand to pluck
those barrels of oil and then down here
is the China the Dragon and the ostrich
this is a via an African colleague of
mine
but it's generally seen as a threat and
I think nowhere is the gap between our
perceptions and the reality of what
China is actually doing in Africa larger
than in the issue of land grabbing an
agricultural investment in Africa so
China has only from 7 to 9 percent of
the world's arable land people disagree
on how much and they have 20 percent of
its population and about 20 years ago
Lester Brown wrote a little book does
anyone know the title of it who will
feed China who will feed China and
Lester Brown wrote this book because as
China was this is 1995 as China had come
out into the market and a middle class
was starting to rise meat consumption
was going up and he was worried that
China's rise was going to shake up
international markets
Royall them that food prices were going
to start spiking and that this was going
to lead to mass starvation around the
world so who will feed China this book
caused a stir in China with these kinds
of predictions and it focused a lot of
attention in Beijing they even invited
Lester Brown there to talk with them
about food security issues and they
worried that a rising middle class would
wreak havoc on global food markets now
during the last global food crisis
around 2007-2008 it looked as though
Lester Brown's predictions were starting
to come true and it looked to many
people as though Africa was going to
play a central role in China's food
security plans so my book
it's title will Africa feed China and
it's an obvious spin on Lester Browns
book and I wish more of you were
familiar with his book because uh then
you would approve my publisher right
because he liked this title as opposed
to the one I wanted
China's African harvest okay so these
the book itself examines for widespread
beliefs about Chinese agricultural
engagement in Africa and the first
belief is that the Chinese have actually
acquired large amounts of land the
second is that the Chinese government is
leading this effort
the third is that the purpose is to grow
food to send back to China and forth
that they're sending Chinese farmers to
do it so let me read to you just a few
things from the introduction which these
are all quotations that have come out in
the media China the chief economist of
the African Development Bank wrote China
is the biggest land grabber in the world
and in Africa and China now has
extensive holdings in African land
acquisitions including pending or
attempted deals for millions of hectares
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
Zambia Zimbabwe Uganda and Tanzania
with many thousands of Chinese workers
brought in to work on these lands
another another quote from an article
from an Israeli news website China's
farms now control most of Zambia's
agriculture and CBS News China recently
purchased half the farm land under
cultivation in the Congo so in terms of
the Chinese government's involvement in
this the Daily Mail wrote the strategy
has been carefully devised by officials
in Beijing and at the Atlantic Council a
researcher said China hasn't invested
immense sums in African agriculture now
about the idea that this is about
feeding China the Rockefeller Foundation
warned that quote the growing Chinese
desire for African produced food could
meet poor people in African countries
may no longer have the resources they
need to survive and in the French
newspaper an NGO and Benina
the Chinese are going vegetables in
Benina and sending them home to China so
finally in terms of sending Chinese
farmers there to grow this this was in
the Economist that more than a million
Chinese farmers were cultivating crops
in Africa Henning Mankell the swedish
crime novelist who's more known for his
fiction than for his fact he said he's a
the weather the the i'm kurt volunter
yes the Kurt Wallander mystery series he
told a journalist I read just the other
day that China has rented land in Kenya
to move some 1 million peasants to
Africa and so on and so on so these are
just a few examples of things that have
been out there in the media and so I
looked into all of these in this recent
book so I actually had a bit of a head
start over a lot of people this is a
picture of me that's me there in the
middle doing my first research in Africa
and as you can see there I'm with
Chinese agricultural experts and
Liberian Ministry of Agriculture experts
on a farm in Liberia and this was in
1984 so I've been looking at what the
Chinese are doing in Africa for quite a
long time now how did we then proceed to
do the research for the current book
well first of all I had a whole team of
research assistants to collect every
example they could find of a Chinese
agricultural investment or purported
investment and eventually we put
together a database of 60 cases and we
looked into them and we did what I call
this is an example here so and on this
you probably can't see because it's very
little but there are two cases here one
says in 2007 China bought 2.8 million
hectares in Congo for biofuel oil
production and the other one says in
2008 they spent 800 million in Mosin
to expand rice production neither of
these things actually ended up happening
but these are the kinds of examples that
we collected and then we did what I call
forensic internet sleuthing and what
this is is basically digging with Google
so it's digging into information on the
internet and trying to track down the
reality and we found quite a bit of
information about these cases
particularly the ones that weren't
actually Chinese so for one example
there was a - supposedly a two billion
dollar Chinese rice investment in
Nigeria and this took about five minutes
to unpack it turned out that it was a
company called Ojeda VT and we googled V
T turns out it's a basmati rice company
from India it wasn't two billion dollars
it turns out it was two billion naira
and then after about five minutes we
found out that this two billion naira
which is about 17 million dollars was to
pay for three rice mills to be imported
from India so there wasn't any Chinese
connected to this at all so that was
just one of the fastest examples of
something that we were able to track
down now so that was one thing that we
did this forensic internet sleuthing but
we also went to these countries and this
is another example back of course in the
day of how I did this but I did this
kind of thing over and over again in
slightly better circumstances now so
this picture here is another Co research
or two researchers that did this in
Mozambique with me Ygritte Eckman from
Sweden
Sergio Qi Chava from Mozambique so we
did fieldwork in 12 countries where the
Chinese were supposed to be doing this
investment we went to the farms if they
existed and if they didn't we talked to
people to try to find out what had
happened and this was a picture from
Zimbabwe when we were following this bus
which was shaking as it went along the
road but I just was thanking my lucky
stars that I wasn't on the bus because
back when I was a student I would be
riding on that bus instead of a in a
friend's car there so the third thing we
did was we track
down everything we could find that the
Chinese have published about their
incentive structure for investment in
agriculture so if they want to grab land
and grow food and so on they would put
some incentives in place to make
companies go and do this and so we
looked at all of the what the banks are
doing what the Ministry of Commerce is
doing on all the seminars they've held
and what the message is that they're
trying to get out to Chinese companies
and this is from a seminar in 2008 on
Chinese Enterprise outbound investment
and this is an example of the 21 largest
projects that we collected at first and
I'm not going to tell you about all of
these here but I'm going to go through
these really quickly to just give you
some basic examples so some of these
were old foreign aid projects that had
been around since the 1960s or 70s and
they weren't actually new investments or
new land grabs so we got rid of some of
those then we found another group that
were farms that Chinese companies had
purchased in the 1990s or or even little
more recently but these were old like 15
year old investments so we got rid of
some of those we also found a number
that a Chinese entrepreneur had made a
big statement about how big the project
was going to be and then when we tracked
it down we found out there wasn't
actually anything that they had done yet
at all so a lot more it disappeared
there in fact I think there and then we
found projects that might happen at some
point they look quite promising but they
haven't happened yet so we couldn't
actually count those and that left us
with just four projects out of those 21
and so that took about two years to get
to that point maybe not quite that long
but these are all projects that we have
either visited at someone on my team is
visited or we have otherwise tracked
down interview the Chinese companies
that have done these investments so
that's pretty small now these are a few
pictures this is from the China Zambia
friendship farm I was there in 2013 this
farm was from 1990 it's an investment
that happened a long time ago and the
man
who was running it has been there since
2006 so I interviewed him and he said to
me I said why are you still here because
usually these Chinese it's a state-owned
company they usually circulate in and
out they're there for three years or so
and then they go home said our daughter
is in the American School in Lusaka and
it's our family's dearest wish that she
come to study in America so we have to
stay here until she graduates from high
school so he also told me that Niall
Ferguson from Harvard had been to
interview him there and and at one point
I asked him I know you're growing wheat
and you're going to soybeans here and
you say you're selling these to the
local market and I've certainly seen a
lot of places where people are buying
these here in Zambia but do you have
intentions to send these to China and he
laughed and he said that's exactly what
Niall Ferguson asked me and he said you
know I said to him if I if anyone wants
to grow soybeans and wheat in Zambia and
send them to China they will have to put
up with making a loss so he obviously
didn't think that's going to be very
profitable so this is a picture which is
a little bit light for you there but it
is one of them random examples of old
aid projects this is from Somalia so
this was done by the Chinese in the
1970s they set it up they left they went
home and then some travelers stumbled
into it who were in Somalia they took
this picture and posted it on the
internet so it's a it's an interesting
example of something from long ago that
that still is there and they still think
of it as a Chinese farm another story
that I want to tell you takes place so
you can't really see this very well at
all well it's a picture of Mozambique
and it's a picture of agriculture but
it's not so important because the story
that I want to tell you takes place not
only in Mozambique but also in Brazil
and it involves the Mozambican names
ideally I met him just last November in
Maputo I had been trying to meet this
guy since 2009 and I finally was able to
track him down you know how I found him
on LinkedIn this is an example of the
sleuthing that we do so he was a
LinkedIn member I'm a LinkedIn member I
sent him a message he
responded and I was going to Mozambique
so we agreed to meet in Maputo he
doesn't live in Maputo but he he was
coming down for business
xiety Ali is a somewhat of Indian
background his family's lived in
Mozambique for three generations and
after the Mozambican Civil War he became
a teacher and then an entrepreneur so he
had a small hotel he had some other
businesses a restaurant in Beira which
is in the north of Mozambique and in
2003 he decided to become a farming
entrepreneur and so he leased 15,000
hectares of from a State Farm as as
Mozambique was privatizing and he wanted
to grow soybeans but he didn't have a
clue about how to grow soybeans and so
he went to Brazil and he studied growing
soybeans he went and talked to a lot of
people there and during the course of
his trip he ran into this Chinese
company that was there buying soybeans
and he ran into them again and they got
to be friendly they stayed in the same
hotel and so he went back to Mozambique
but he had their business cards and as
he sat there in Mozambique he thought he
brought back someone from Brazil to help
him with the farm but he kept thinking
about those Chinese and eventually he
contacted them and mate in Beijing went
to Beijing proposed that they do a joint
venture and they were interested when
they came back to Mozambique in about
2005 he showed them the land they
decided they could work together and
they started a joint venture and in the
first two years they had a disaster so
there was a drought and there were an
insect infestation there was no
infrastructure there to actually figure
out what the problem was with the
insects and what kind of chemicals to
use no extension agents no Research
Center and then the company he was
investing with which was China Green and
oils Corporation was part was a it was
acquired by kafka China's big commodity
traders so there was a big thing of
mergers and acquisitions and they got
caught they got bought and cough co
decided to can the Mozambique project
so they pulled out and it failed inside
e alley lost a lot of money so he told
me about this and I said he said I
almost lost my restaurant he said and in
my hotel I'd use them as collateral for
for the mortgage to invest in the farm
and but he said you know those Chinese I
learned so much from them and if they
want to come back I'm here so that was
an investment that didn't happen another
one then let me tell you about this one
this was supposed to be the 2.8 million
hectare investment in the DRC this was
going to be actually a very large
investment and it was something to set
up by a Chinese telecommunications
company John Chang's
ZTE telecoms so ZTE did come to the
Congo they were interested in doing a
biofuels investment they wanted to
acquire a lot of land so all of this is
true they really wanted to do this but I
want kawin who was their general manager
the regional manager for the DRC and his
boss back in Shenzhen where ZTE has this
headquarters had decided to set up an
energy company so they were moving into
other sectors and bio fields was
something they were very interested in
so they came to the Congo to see if they
could get land there and the Congolese
government was thrilled the they came in
saying we want to make a really big
investment can you get a really big
parcel of land for us eventually they
were able to get permission from the
Congolese to have a hundred thousand
hectares which would have been a really
large investment not 2.3 or 2.8 million
hectare is the way it was described but
still quite large so Wonka when told me
what happened next he said that they
were show in the area of land that they
were given and it was way in the
interior of the Congo along the Congo
River and so they took planes and he
brought experts in to look at the land
they they flew above it and then they
landed in the local Airport and they
took soil samples and it all looked
quite promising but the experts said to
him you know you
have to build an oil palm refinery here
to refine this into biofuel and it's
going to have to be right here because
you can't bring those fruits out they'll
spoil so you're gonna have to bring
everything up the river there aren't any
roads and so Wonka Wynne said all right
I'll bring in a team of River experts
from China and we'll take a boat up the
river and they did that they hired a
boat and they started going up the river
to check out whether or not this could
become their highway and almost
immediately they had problems so broke
the boat broke down at least three times
they kept hitting sandbars because the
river is not it's a natural river it
hasn't ever been carved out for big boat
traffic and so the river experts said to
Wonka Winn it's gonna take a hundred
years to basically get this river in the
shape that you need to be able to make
this a commercial investment and so that
investment also did not go forward they
did end up with a 200 hectare pilot
project and finally the last project
that I want to tell you about is is
actually a project that looks very much
like an African project it's come humble
Kalani who is the person there on the
left
combo Kalani fury is a Zambian who got a
Chinese government scholarship to go and
study in China he did a civil
engineering degree and while he was
there he met the woman who would later
become his wife
and he fell in love and so when he
graduated he didn't want to go back to
Zambia quite yet and so he got a job
with a Chinese energy company and this
Chinese energy company was basically
doing biofuel and other renewable
energies in China but they were ready to
move out
and so Kumba Kalani suggested to them
that they come to Africa they had been
thinking about Indonesia and they and he
said he would go and check it out so he
came to Zambia which is where he was
from and he met up with Thomson sakala
who was Zambian also interested in
biofuels and so the two of them
Thompson sakala and kuma Kalani theory
were the ones at the news conference
when it was announced that China had
requested two million hectares to do
biofuels in Zambia so of course they're
sitting there both Zambian but this was
a supposed to be a Chinese request a
Chinese government request no less and
this was a private company so this two
million hectare request for land ends up
boiling down to with a lot of back and
forth and it's all being run by Thompson
cicala and Khumbu Kalani theory it ends
up being seventy nine thousand Hector's
that are eventually approved for
allocation but this has to be approved
by the president because it's such a
large chunk of land and there's an
election on and so the president is
hesitant to approve it then he loses the
election the new president comes in his
name is Michael Sata he's not a friend
of the Chinese in fact he was elected on
an anti Chinese platform and so Michael
Sata says
seventy-nine thousand hectares for
Chinese projects too big I'll let you
have two thousand and they said we can't
get economies of scale with two thousand
as a pilot project and so that project
also ends up not going forward so so
what are the Chinese actually doing in
Africa they are active in agriculture
but their their goals are a lot
different than what we thought with
those four areas of conventional wisdom
so first of all the Chinese have not
acquired very much land if you look at
the the 6,000 hectares that if you add
all those 60 cases up at six thousand
hectares and what we found is that
Chinese had actually acquired about
240,000 Hector's so it's much smaller
than you imagined and the Chinese
government is not leading us in fact the
companies kept complaining that the
government was not supporting them and
not helping them and on the third about
what they were interested in growing
they're interested in biofuels they're
interested in rubber they're interested
in tobacco cotton but they were not
interested in growing food to send back
to China and then the fourth we found no
evidence of Chinese farmers coming over
in large numbers to Africa in fact the
the there are some small Chinese farms
are and I'll show you one in a moment
but the people that are investing in
farming are not from China are not
usually farmers they are investors and
entrepreneurs and they're coming into
that sector because they think they can
make money rather than coming because
they're losing land in China or
something like that so the Chinese have
24 agricultural demonstration projects
each of these combines of Chinese
business usually to run it and to set it
up and it's supposed to be a business
platform so that's one thing they are
interested in doing in merging together
business and and foreign aid so that's
something they've done successfully many
times before and I would say that this
doesn't sound like something that we do
except very recently we've gotten this
new alliance for food security and
nutrition out of the g8 and the u.s. is
one of the members of this and so this
is the way that our foreign aid agency
is working together with American
companies to try to work on on food
security in Africa so I thought that was
quite interesting the Chinese started
doing it earlier than we did but they're
also working with their companies to
have the aid program to work on
agricultural engagement and try to get
business to be on part a part of that so
this is another example of one of these
agro technology demonstration centers
and this one isn't Zimbabwe and it's run
by a Chinese company that basically
sells Chinese machinery and in this
sense they're also following in our
footsteps so this is an example of a
John Deere tractor that we also have a
market although this actually comes from
Brazil but it is an American company and
they have this is another agro
technology demonstration Center in
Cameroon and this is a company that
thought they would set the center up and
then they would invest in a big project
and they ended up still after it from
2005 to the present they only have a
hundred hector's they're also teaching
their rice technology to men which is
kind of interesting because in that area
it's usually women who do this area of
production and they're also interested
in style
their services and their high technology
for example this is un loan paying high
tech group they're running at least two
of the agro technology demonstration
centers in Africa and they want to
basically they're in crop science and
they do a lot of research and hybrids
other areas of upgraded seeds and that's
what they would like to do in Africa so
finally this is construction so this is
an example from Angola of a Chinese
company that has is helping the Angolan
government they're building state farms
for angola and constructing them and
then providing technical assistance to
get them up and running so that's
another area of business that they're
looking at these are the small farms you
can't really see very many chinese
farmers here but let me just show you
just right up here you can see a few
Chinese the rest of these are all
Zambian farmers in the local market but
these Chinese guys these are actually
both of these are buying but they're
buying from a Chinese farmer who's
selling the Chinese spring onions there
were there wasn't a lot of selection but
spring onions were popular there and
then finally here is a woman I talked to
in Mozambique she's in a big Chinese
project which is one of the largest we
found 20,000 hectares and that's a
picture of it over on the right there
but she's a contract farmer for this
company and so they have contract
farmers that are growing rice in this
case and then selling it to the company
which is an Agri processing company so
what does China want and who's going to
feed China this is a picture from Brazil
basically China is importing its food
the soy beans and the corn that it's
using to feed its pigs and its chickens
and it's important it from the Americas
so the corn is coming from the United
States and the soy beans are coming from
Argentina and Brazil and so far it
doesn't look as though Africa is going
to be a major supplier of these
commodities so let me end by telling you
one more little story which is that in
1966 the first President of Congo
Brazzaville
wrote the
Africa was under threat of a Chinese
Communist colonization and I'm quoting
him here coherent logical and terribly
effective which would in due course turn
the entire continent into a gigantic
rice field so this was a concern back in
1966 of course this didn't happen and
it's not happening now the Chinese are
not building a new empire in Africa
rather Chinese firms are part of a new
wave of globalization this really
started for the Chinese in the 1980s as
their reforms are happening at home
Chinese agribusiness companies are going
out in the footsteps of companies alike
Swiss see giant Syngenta US tractor
manufactured John Deere the European
commodities firm louis-dreyfus and even
Firestone Tire which is the American of
big plantation in Liberia they also have
their biggest investment is actually a
rubber plantation the Chinese biggest
investment is a rubber plantation in
Cameroon that they purchased from the
Cameroonian government so they are as
Edward Steinfeld has said they're
playing our game and the sooner we
realize this the sooner we'll be
prepared to work more constructively
with China to help ensure that Africa
one day will be able to feed itself and
then perhaps in the not-too-distant
future also helped to feed China thank
you
because I don't think that Africa is a
political battleground between the West
and China I think actually the China and
both sides I think understand that their
their interests are quite complementary
in a way so for example in our aid
program we put a lot of money into
health the Chinese put very little into
health but they put a lot of money into
infrastructure we don't put much into
infrastructures so we're keeping more
people alive and they're providing the
infrastructure that's going to enable
them to get to the hospitals and and so
on and get the the medicines in and go
for treatment so there's a lot of
complementarity there I do think there's
a concern more generally in the West
about China's rise and so we see this
most recently in the South China Sea so
that's become a very headline issue we
see it with concern about the Asian
infrastructure investment bank and the
u.s. made what I think is a stupid
decision not to join you know we're when
it's the US and Japan and I think even
the UK joined so it's basically it's
kind of the US and Japan and if it
decided not to go in and so I think
there is there's more but that fits in
with the idea that there's a threat
there and that we should distance
ourselves from it rather than I think
in Europe they were much more
constructive about joining in with AIB
and deciding to work inside and that's
so to answer the second part of your
question I do think a lot of this is
lazy journalism but it's the kind of
journalism that got through all the
editors because it fit a preconceived
notion that we had about what China
wants no land lots of people surely
they're gonna want to export all those
people to Africa and a lot of people in
Africa believe that as well it even
seemed like a good idea to some Chinese
so it hasn't become a government policy
but there are Chinese are said why don't
we do it what a great idea
my question to you would be would you
see China's role both in terms i i have
learnt this book and i agree with his
argument from what i can see its it is
african investors who are the ones that
are making are the most interested
although the if you look at the data on
some of these databases it looks like
it's still european and american in
terms of the largest number with the
chinese not so big anymore this is a
very complicated question and i don't
know how i can give an easy answer to
this i do in the book have a whole
chapter in which i look at all of these
questions about commercial agriculture
in africa and what this means and this
is a hugely controversial area if you
want to take if you want to look at a
Marxist perspective on this I think
Marxist would say that in a lot of parts
of Africa you are in a pre capitalist
situation in which primitive
accumulation hasn't happened yet does
anyone even know what that term means
primitive accumulation
primitive accumulation yeah maybe you
haven't heard that for decades have you
ha ha
anyway the idea of primitive
accumulation is that the first stages of
capitalism basically you have to get
land and you have to invest in the land
then and and get your profits from that
and then you accumulate that and then
you put that into other areas like
manufacturing and so on that's that's
from that perspective but you can look
at it from a completely different you
don't have to look at Marx to try to
understand something about how African
rural areas are largely pre capitalist
or not capitalist so it's subsistence
farming what does that mean for the
future will they be able to retain that
well we well they turn into small yeoman
farmers who you know each one is is part
of the market and part of and staying
there on the farm and improving their
technology that has not been the pattern
in most parts of the world it has been
like in Taiwan even China's
consolidating more but those those
questions about what the future is for
rural Africa are extremely contentious
and many African governments do not
believe that the future lies with the
subsistence farmer and bringing them
into the market and commercializing that
so they look at that as backward they
just want to bring in big investors and
commercialize on a big scale so I don't
have the answer to that I know the
rental is one of the people who believes
very much on the small-scale farmer the
World Bank is very big on that although
that's also they have a division of
opinion there about the role for scale
scaling up agriculture so where does it
where the Chinese fit they'll fit
wherever the incentive structure points
them basically if there's if there's
interest in having them come in by the
government by African government they'll
explore it and if it they want it to be
big scale they would be interested they
just couldn't make it happen it's not to
say that they they're just good guides
and they didn't do it out of the
goodness of their heart they wanted to
they just didn't want to grow food to
send back to China but they would have
liked to do biofuels back when that
looked like it would be profitable
yes my name is Ellen Show a little
louder yeah I've been to see your table
and the many investment in that way as
well in what sector ago so I agree with
you that there is not much trade between
China and Africa in terms of agriculture
because all the shape-shifter whose many
in China to Africa but when they came
back is always active so there is much
not much trading but I observed one
thing that is especially in soup here
there is a huge construction everywhere
good everywhere using console
construction and it is a really huge
clearly in China has been investing in
Africa contracting sector
what's the purpose of that they make
money from it because most of the
construction I assume is from
the first Chinese companies to do
construction projects in Africa for
profit but not for the Chinese
government this happened in 1979 so
those companies were there doing Chinese
aid projects and then as China moved to
the market and the responsibility system
was developed so that companies that
belong to ministries could seek profits
and then they could keep some of that
profit for themselves those companies
that were there building China's foreign
aid projects started looking for
contracts that they could get and I saw
this happening all through the 80s so
they were there already so in in Nigeria
this is where this happened in India and
those companies have been bidding on
contracts ever since so you can look at
the the data on this the turnover and
contracts from overseas business in the
construction sector this is published
every year and it just keeps getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and in
Africa now this is about I think it's
about a quarter of the business now
maybe even more is just coming from
Africa this offshore business and it is
about over 40 billion dollars a year of
turnover for Chinese companies in Africa
doing these construction projects and
these are not mostly financed by the
Chinese I would say at most 25% and so
in Ethiopia there are a few really big
ones but there are a lot of roads and
other things that are being done in
Ethiopia that are not fine outside of
Chinese loans in Nigeria very active
they're doing projects all over the
country and it's for those state
governments and Nigeria has oil wealth
and this goes out to the state so they
hired Chinese companies to build
infrastructure and it happens all over
so lots of private government and so on
and this is a Africa every year should
be spending 90 billion dollars on
infrastructure and they're spending a
lot less than that but the Chinese
companies would like to get every single
one of those contracts and it is
profitable it's also very competitive so
I think the profit margins are low but
there it is profitable
so it seems that for any type of kind of
transfer particularly to large
population a lot of rivers and I'm
wondering is this something that's
purely solved through either the private
sector or through for infrastructure
they're up most of this is going to have
to be done by governments because there
aren't that many cases where you can do
things like roads in Africa where it
could be profitable to have a
public-private partnership like having a
toll road you really need to have a
density and there aren't that many
examples there only two that I know of
that Chinese companies are interested in
they're actually doing toll roads one is
in Ethiopia and the other one is in
Uganda and all the other roads that they
built are not toll roads they're all
ones for governments or mostly for
governments and then the governments are
maintaining them so that has to be a
government investment there are
possibilities for public-private
partnerships imports so there is
interest on that and there aren't two nd
that I've gotten really far along but
there's a lot of interest all around the
continent on the west the East the South
in the port infrastructure and the
railroads railroads that the Chinese are
building are all for African governments
so that again in Ethiopia in Nigeria in
Angola and now this one that's going
from across Kenya up to Uganda and maybe
beyond and hooking up possibly down with
the tans and real way that was built so
long ago by the Chinese so these
infrastructure projects are they're
pretty much done some financed by the
Chinese I would say about ten you know
from 8 to 11 or 12 billion a year no
more than that and probably less foreign
aid in general and this is not mostly
foreign aid funding from the Chinese
some of it is but a lot of it is not
it's a commercial rate our government
has not been funding much infrastructure
we
it's just not what we do and the
Europeans don't fund that much either
the World Bank is starting to move into
that but they had also really moved away
from it so there weren't really a lot of
other possible sources for that funding
and the Chinese for them that was
win-win because all of their funding is
tied to Chinese companies impractical
son so it's generating business for the
firms that were already there and some
of them are new and coming in and
getting that business as well so one
last thing about infrastructure which is
that in China there's a saying yo
xiangfu Zhang show Luo which is if you
want to become prosperous first build a
road they really believe this and Norman
Borlaug who was the father of the Green
Revolution he once said about Africa
that it needs three things roads roads
and roads so this ideas out there that
you need roads in order to to move up
the development ladder or do you believe
that the college could be especially in
terms of like the African president
would be a big part of foreign policy
I think that from what I hear from the
African side they're very interested in
partnering with China I don't think that
the Chinese they have for example
there's a China Africa agricultural
investment fund but it's just 1 billion
renminbi which is about 161 million
dollars it's not very big and that's
like for all of Africa so there's and I
don't see that they want to put a whole
lot because they and they're having a
lot of trouble finding investable
opportunities you know once but they
think they can make money so for the
government they're not going to put a
lot of foreign aid money into those
because they don't have a lot of foreign
aid money they don't have really big
they do construction really through the
foreign aid and I don't think that
they're gonna put a lot of investment
money into it cuz it just by and large
right now it's not looking that
promising and even for the future so let
me give you an example of where they are
putting their money that's related to
agriculture there's a line of credit
just one Chinese company which is COFF
Co the big commodities trader they have
a line of credit from I think China
Development Bank it might be also from
Exim Bank but is 9 billion dollars just
for one company and that is to go into
the commodity markets and to become a
commodity trader and to set up those
silos and and do that kind of work so
that's what they want they want to right
now they believe they can feed the
Chinese through the commodity markets
buying in America buying in Brazil I
hope we don't do something that shakes
that confidence because that would be
that would really be a problem
in the extractive industry in terms of
oil in Africa is China's interest in the
biofuels interest really comes out of
that same period of around 2008 or so
when when prices were high they weren't
just high for food they were also high
for oil and so this was oil prices were
very high and a lot of companies thought
that biofuels would be a really good
investment but then the oil prices
crashed and they're really low now so
biofuels are not a good investment
anymore
and most of the Chinese companies were
not who looked into biofuels we're
looking in Asia so they were looking in
Indonesia even the Philippines Papua New
Guinea they're not in Africa there very
few examples
you mentioned some political problems in
Zambian Congo and sort of pushing out
the Chinese are there particular regions
that wait no I think that uh Zambia is
kind of unique in that they the Chinese
presence became an issue in their
presidential elections not just once
several times and so that was there
aren't any other countries that I can
think right now where it was really like
a top-level issue in a presidential
campaign Zambia didn't push the Chinese
out they just were they didn't approve
that one investment there's still a lot
of Chinese investors in Zambia and the
largest the country where most China the
most Chinese investments on the largest
value is South Africa so that is a very
attractive area still for Chinese to
invest they also have come a lot to
Nigeria which is not you know terribly
attractive an investment environment I
talked to one Chinese shoe company there
and they had had one branch they had
invested in Russia and one that had
invested in Nigeria and so they said
they were closing the one in Russia and
bringing it to Nigeria because it was a
better investment environment so I think
that's the kind of comparison they were
making it with LA betterthan and then in
Russia so by and large Chinese
investment has been welcomed the one
area where it's been more controversial
I think has aside from Zambia for local
people it has been in things that have
environmental impact or in labor
relations so those are more problems
with labor relations these are cultural
issues that are quite contentious and
very serious and the thing I hear the
most complaints about is labor relations
and African employees and Chinese
managers and then the environment is
also an issue with regard to Chinese
demand for for protected species I hear
about that and forestry so if
for a species animal species there's a
lot of demand in China for these and
that's a problem I thought it was
interesting hearing how you talk about a
lot of these projects that ultimately
didn't get off the ground you know they
seemed promising at first and it seems
like someone to go to negotiation
processes or undertaking these projects
with China and it seems pretty complex
I'm wondering how this compares to
projects at the World Bank or other
Development Bank's might take on so I
mean it seems like China doesn't
necessarily want to force situations to
happen if there isn't like a scenario is
that right does the world banks a lot of
projects or well you're really comparing
an an apple and an orange there because
the projects that I've been talking
about are all investment projects these
are all like you know private investment
even sometimes it might be a state-owned
company its private investment what the
World Bank funds is is development
projects and so and those are all
negotiated with the government and the
World Bank is providing something that
the government wants and it's providing
a loan so that they can carry it out so
there's not it wouldn't get cancelled at
the end because of some kind of
difficulty with and they don't do areas
that things that take a whole lot of
land usually it's not a big land
intensive direction so they wouldn't
have the same kind of experience but
what you didn't ask him what I will
answer now is whether or not investors
from other countries to have the same
kinds of problems and I'd say absolutely
and I was told that over and over again
the Chinese said to me that they talked
to other people like from Brazil Europe
and so on they said everybody's having
trouble so it's not just us so it's
difficult and I think that ultimately
that suggests that it's difficult to
invest in Africa and certainly investing
in agriculture is really hard and that's
why so few of these really large land
grab investments have actually gone
forward and I think that's pretty I know
it's true for the Chinese because I've
investigated this in my new deed
but I have a colleague who's done it for
the Gulf states in you know the Qatar
and Abu Dhabi and all of those countries
and he found the same thing they had the
same kinds of problems and there was
very little land transfer that actually
happened for them either now this could
all change at some point and I was
hoping it didn't change before the book
was finished but you know if if food
prices spiked up again this might or if
oil prices spiked up again it creates
new incentives for the biofuels and so
on but I think this first wave for the
Chinese anyway they it was a bitter
experience for these companies and the
word is out that's not easy and I think
future companies coming in will be a
little bit more conservative in terms of
the amount of land that they might
request or how big they think their
investment can be
and I assumed that there are people's
life who rent life on this land and
changed their lives well that's a good
question that last part I don't know but
the first part is that most of this land
that was under discussion was under
traditional land holding systems so some
of it the ones that were successful
actually are the ones in which it used
to be a state farm or it was an
acquisition of an existing plantation
those those things were successful but
the ones where it was all traditional
land this gets into the complications of
land tenure systems in Africa so there
is an assumption in many countries that
the government owns all the land you
know all the government but yet there's
also their overlapping land tenure
systems so their traditional land tenure
systems to where the land is sort of is
owned by tribal groups and communities
and so these came into conflict because
the government said to the Chinese
investors yes we can allocate land for
you and then they found that actually it
wasn't so easy because they had to
convince these traditional communities
to give over the land and they have a
hard time doing that and people
protested when they thought they were
going to be moved off their land and so
there very few cases in which they were
that they went ahead and really moved
people off so that gets to the your
final part of that question which is can
people go back to the land most the time
they never left so it never got to the
point where they had to leave and so the
project didn't go forward they still are
on the land and so on
my question has to do with corruption in
Africa and a lot of people would contend
that one of Africa's most significant
developmental challenges is not just an
avoidance of conflict but is actually
managing corruption and mainly within
the government unlike the United States
or the UK or we see China does not have
an enforceable Convention Against
Corruption like the firm for a practice
act or PSA do you think that China and
essentially is a net contributor to
African corruption let me address that
in three ways or it with three points
the first is that the Chinese actually
if you look at the history of trying to
combat corruption in the United States
has really taken a leading role there we
signed the Foreign Corrupt Practices Act
in 1977 and it took another 20 years
before the Europeans signed it they
signed on with the OECD Convention
Against Corruption so now Europe is on
board as well but if you look at any of
the research on how that's enforced its
enforced very poorly so look across
Europe they're not enforcing by and
large very well their own corrupt
practices the Chinese actually do have
legislation now on Foreign Corrupt
Practices this was as a result of
signing the UN Convention but we don't
know whether or not it's enforceable it
doesn't look like it we don't know what
the mechanisms are so that's just
background for this so are the Chinese
making corruption worse this is
something that my friend Paul Collier
said in the bottom billion and I took
him to task for that because I say you
don't have any evidence on this it's
possible certainly Chinese companies are
ranked along with Indian companies as
the most likely to pay bribes of all the
foreign companies operating in Africa
but on the other hand the way the
Chinese fund their infrastructure
projects through these lot these big
loans the money never goes into the
African government it stays in China and
it's used to pay the company there and
so what that does it it reduces
embezzlement risk and we have a lot of
banks operating in places like Angola
where they're just channeling large
amounts of money to the Angolan
government with no strings attached at
all and that is a huge risk for
embezzlement and we've actually seen
this coming out in places like
Equatorial Guinea as well so the Chinese
I think contribute to reducing the risk
of embezzlement with the way they
finance projects they probably increase
the risk of kickbacks with the way they
obtain the projects and possibly be
persecuted under the FCA in that respect
China perhaps is not the best partner
well I'm not saying that China is the
best partner for Africa they have I'm
saying that that there's the there's a
lot of corruption in China and there's a
lot of corruption in Africa so I'm sure
there is a lot of corruption happening
in Chinese engagement in Africa I'm not
sure that that is the worst the worst
thing that's impeding development on the
continent there is this joke however of
you know the joke that I heard it was at
the Kennedy School sorry about som
students who may be in the audience but
you had a Nigerian and a Korean who had
been students at the Kennedy School and
the Nigerian went to visit the Korean
and he they both end up working for the
government and the Korean lived in a
really nice apartment and so the
Nigerians said well how did you afford
this and he said look at that bridge of
10% so and so a year later the Korean
went to visit the Nigerian and he lived
in a palatial house and he said how
could you afford this on your government
salary he said you look at that bridge
and the Korean said what bridge and he
said hundred percent
you know so there are it could be that
the scale of corruption is a lot higher
but certainly in East Asia there's been
a lot of corruption and a lot of
development too so it's it may it's it's
not a positive force but it may not be
the thing that's really holding Africa
back well they're concerned about food
security make no mistake about that they
just don't see that Africa is going to
be supplying their food and this is what
the government's been saying all along
and officials would say things like you
know we can't rely on Africa for our
food how could we like people are
starving in Africa okay we'd like to
inspect them it could come and send food
to China so what I see them doing is
basically looking for a lot of different
options and obtaining food in Latin
America in rice I think they're going to
continue to do rice and wheat at home so
they'll probably go in the direction
that Japan went on rice and in Japan
they have 800 percent tariffs on rice so
they protect their local rice farmers
their rice self-sufficient I imagine
that China will probably move in that
direction with the rice and wheat but
they are our movie they're doing the
globalization thing they bought
Smithfield farms which is our big pork
producer here so they're they're moving
out to acquire companies mergers
acquisitions and so on which is what
we've been doing so I do think it'll be
a more normal kind of food supply
situation in which it involves trade and
and not the thing about trying to grow
it yourself and then somehow you know
secure that and send it all the way back
the way we thought it was going to
happen or the way many people thought
was going to happen
which is about thankful in some Chinese
garment to African countries I've heard
that the Chinese disputing military
training academy in Zimbabwe and I still
remember that when South Sudan also that
have a complicated coupling to the
President to China so we're trying to
play well they play a positive role in
African politics you know I think the
Chinese in general don't want to be
involved in African politics so they
really would prefer just to stay out of
that from what I can see this non
interference policy is just a lot more
convenient than trying to get involved
in the actual in politics rip in terms
of elections or in terms of trying to
influence they would like when it comes
to influencing for business yes they
would want to influence governments to
choose them they want to influence
governments to build things and then
have Chinese banks finance them and so
on and that's where the Zimbabwe
Military Academy comes in this is a
construction project so the the company
that built that wanted to build a big
project that Zimbabwean government the
Defense Department loved the idea it's
this huge I've been there it's this huge
it basically looks like a real estate
development not of Military Academy it's
got a house after house after house and
it's quite nice looking with the whole
fence around it and this was secured
with diamonds from a joint venture
between the construction company and the
Ministry of Defense and they the profits
from that diamond mind that they
invested in together are repaying the
loan which is actually a foreign aid
long that built that military academy so
would this help is somehow going to
bolster Mugabe quite possibly it is
certainly strengthening the military and
providing nice places for the generals
to live absolute
it's interesting there's a similar
military college being built in Namibia
which is you know just down the way from
Zimbabwe no one ever talks about that
one but and I think there's also one in
Tanzania but there are other the Chinese
build things and they'll build things
for the military they'll build things
they'll build things for the Ministry of
Health whatever you want
I wonder can you comment on my way
because I think always has been dominant
countries and it seems like Chinese
companies
in the market or the labor instead
hallway is one of the largest telecoms
companies in the world and they are they
have a big rivalry with Junction
telecommunications ZTE and they are
together there in a lot of African
countries competing with each other like
in Ethiopia that both they've competed
quite a bit hallway I would say that
most of what they do in Africa is not so
much investment like they don't buy
things they don't own things they have
their own companies but they provide
services so they will build things and
when you look at how the Teleca telecoms
revolution in Africa has been
extraordinary
you can get cell phone reception in very
remote parts of Ethiopia now you can
take your cheap handset and you can find
out the price of your agricultural
commodities or you can call someone if
your wife is in labor to try to help her
to get to a hospital you just have that
communications ability now and it is
because Huawei and Johnson
telecommunications are building that
infrastructure across the continent for
Vodafone and for MTN and for all of the
African telecoms companies that actually
own it so they don't own that stuff they
just build it and maintain it and that
takes having offices all over the place
and training academies so one of the
projects we want to look at is the
training academies of hallway because
it's really interesting there are
cycling Africans through these training
academies so that they can man these
projects because otherwise they were
bringing people in from Europe and China
to do it and it was too expensive
governments in in Africa are not some of
them are not very open to Chinese
investments they are different different
so in your opinion what is why there are
some countries that I'm sorry if I gave
the impression that some countries feel
like they aren't open to Chinese
investment because I think every country
in Africa is is open for Chinese
investment there are some in which
they've had problems and some in which
the challenges have been bigger and some
in which the labor relations have been
fierce and intense so their problems
with a lot of these in and lots of
different stories about that I told you
some of those stories on agriculture but
I don't know of a single case where I
where the country itself is not there
may be individuals within it there may
be civil society groups that are
suspicious about the Chinese certainly
in South Africa that would be the case
but in general the investment is there's
a welcome there's a real welcome they'd
like having and they like it because as
a Nigerian said to me you know the West
comes to Nigeria and they are interested
in oil oil and nothing but oil but the
Chinese come and they're interested in
every sector of our economy and we like
that Michael Sata
yeah Michael Sata he uses as is in his
election campaign he said the Chinese
are in festers not investors he was he
said if he was elected he would
recognize Taiwan he was elected he
didn't recognize Taiwan so he was
useless as a campaign tool and he got
elected and then after he got elected
the first person he invited to the
presidential mansion was the Chinese
ambassador so basically of saying I was
just kidding
well American politicians have been
known to do the same thing with respect
to the Chinese but before I do all our
proceedings to close let me just say
that after the lecture please join us
upstairs on the second floor for a
reception and continue the conversation
thank you so much has really been a
treat to listen to you this afternoon
thank you very good question
thank you